there are new questions today about the
health and future of California Senator
Dianne Feinstein 89 years old the
Democrat has been absent from the Senate
business or from the Senate from all
Senate business rather recovering from
illness and now some of her fellow
Democrats claim that she can no longer
do her job and she should quit Scott
McFarland is on Capitol Hill for us
Scott this is quite a talker good
morning
toning in a narrowly divided U.S Senate
Dianne Feinstein is a pivotal vote at a
pivotal moment she's the oldest U.S
senator and has been absent now for two
months as she recovers from shingles in
a statement last night she said her
return to Washington has been delayed
due to continued complications and also
in a rare request she asked Senate
Democratic leaders to temporarily fill
her seat on the pivotal Senate Judiciary
Committee that panel's work confirming
federal judges has been partially
stalled in her absence Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer last night said he
would do so but over the past 24 hours
some house Democrats including
California's Roe Khanna have urged her
to step down ahead of the 2024 elections
saying Feinstein can no longer fulfill
her duties her office announced she will
not run for reelection next year but
says she will be back here when doctors
determine it's safe for her to resume
traveling Gail
all right Scott thank you very much